opposers I love this country it's where
I was born it's where I do this show and
it is definitely where I will die unless
my space laser tag Park idea gets off
the ground sadly these days I'm seeing
this country change and not the good
ways like when a forest becomes a
Walmart no sometimes when I look around
I don't recognize my country anymore
[Applause]
[Music]
first up the family from getting married
to raising children today's American
family resembles more of a Canadians
legal marijuana fever dream than the
traditional unit we know and love just
look at what's happening to marriage
take a look at this these dermal wedding
piercings are what's hot right now for
newlyweds so you can see here there's no
ring the diamonds are actually connected
to a base that's Pierce under the skin
what what getting that diamond implanted
into your hand like you're living in
Elizabeth Taylor's police states not on
my watch which is above the skin by the
way I mean look at that ring that's
gotta hurt the ring isn't supposed to be
the painful part that's the wedding
night there was so much blood I lost
almost a pint
look American matrimony is about two
things
the permanent bond of marriage and the
freedom to break that permanent bond and
then create a new permanent bond for a
little while and then break that bond
and then create yet another permanent
bond with a slovenian model and then
temporarily remove that bond when you
meet a porn star to golf tournament
which to be clear is not what happened
but surgically implanted diamonds is
that how we do it now
is this even America maybe it's not
maybe it's Brazil and I'm a sexy
brazilian boy with a mullet playing
beach volleyball with my even six-year
friends with even longer mullets and
waxing all of the hair off of our bodies
before we watch the big game which is
just soccer all the while chat about how
great it is that we stayed in the Paris
climate Accord now but yeah yeah
is this even America anymore I know I
have to beg for clapper I can't even
believe it
the erosion of America doesn't just stop
at marriage
oh no remember when people used to give
their babies normal names like Donald
and Eric and Ivanka and the other one
well you can kiss those days goodbye the
online media website courts found
neutral baby names are pretty popular
the name charlie which a century ago was
almost exclusively a name for boys but
now 51 percent of all Charlie's are
actually girls that's true it's a very
cute name oh yeah charlie is a cute name
for boys it's Charlie's Angels not
Charlie's Charlie's genders are like
electrical outlets babies need them to
learn take my son's truck a Toledo
every year I give them both a power tool
a book of maps and four seconds of eye
contact you know stuff boys like we need
gendered names so we know which children
are girls who have too many emotions and
which children are boys who should
suppress all of those emotions I love
your dad but is this what it's come to
is this even America or is this Malta
Italy's Hawaii and I've just session
down the beautiful Mediterranean coast
snacking on 13 centimeter long star goo
listen all the Maltese people brag about
their female president who they elected
in 2014 well guess what hung out with
her you hear that buddy louisiana break
it oh look the kids aren't all right
even the ones who do have gender Dame's
they're all wrapped up at a dangerous
new trend there's a new smoking trend
it's and a growing number of high
schools nationwide yeah this thing is
called jeweling so Jul looks just like a
thumb drive you can actually plug it
into a computer to charge it and when
you puff it you get a shot of nicotine
just like a cigarette now students
across America are using them in the
classroom it is the sleekest coolest
high-tech product I have seen in a long
time my man
this guy knows sleek and cool products
just last year he hit me to a pretty
sweet tv/vcr combo come on kids don't
give in to peer pressure
just because this cool guy is telling
you that julene is the thing to do that
doesn't mean you have to do it
I mean if he drove his 1983 Saturn off a
bridge slowly by mistake because he was
a bit sleepy I mean would you know be an
individual this Julian thing is a
terrifying trend not because kids are
getting hooked on nicotine that'll give
a about that no but whatever
happened to good old fashioned
cigarettes I mean these kids talk about
these dual devices being small and
discreet like those are positives kids
no one could see you're smoking how do
we know you're cool when I was younger
the cool kids were always panty nerds
smoking cigs and butt chuggin Boone's
Farm now every teen in America's voting
protest scene and puffing on USB drives
nothing about this is cool or American
am I even in my country anymore or am I
in New Zealand and I'm sipping Sauvignon
Blanc with my sheep gazing off into an
ocean that's completely free from oil
rings because they just banned offshore
drilling climate changes in the issue
guys why don't you do something about
all those immigrant hobbits flooding the
border Chuck Chuck bring me back tell me
I'm still in the country I love is our
favorite salad still potato followed by
pasta tuna and marshmallow nice do yoga
studios a better teacher to student
ratios than public schools and more
books nice are there more podcasts than
people I just started one I'm not gonna
listen but I am relieved thanks Chuck
the fight continues
[Music]